the center looking for images that it totally fought for it is already part of your visual memory this is a series that calls mega pixels in photos from magazines right and it is precisely you trying to create a winning situation recreating a technological solution with content that already exists but when  you are faced with it on a large scale you will begin to realize that this image is made up of thousands of pieces of another image you will be subject to a series of small tenders that you are always trying to recover and negotiate this relationship between the detail is  that the entirety of the image the first thing when you look at an image study it once the door to the party has decided we start trying to look in magazines a little then
take out pages to create a
situation where the origin of these
small images does not seem that
can you identify a singular source
where the images are coming from the idea of
already being able to make a whole song with
small break  ininhos right support with the hand
to avoid gold
also I use the scanner that gives me
an image with a resolution of a few
gigapixels
this will be the final scale in this scale
you can also see the ref tony is the
plot of these images that they were
company  the fact that they were printed
with very low resolution
you are seeing something
very sharp and very out of focus at the same time
this ambiguity is very interesting
just
the sound